That's the parser, and I know we went really quick.
We didn't have time to go over a lot of the details.
If you hadn't seen anything about parsing or languages before,
I may have been too fast for you and I apologize.
But part of the idea was to teach a little bit about language theory,
but more the idea was just to give you a tool
and to show you how these tools are built and how you can use them.
Don't worry if you didn't get all the details of exactly how the parser works.
If you are interested, there's another course and there's some other documentation
that you can read to get up to speed on it.
But I just want to talk about one more thing.
There's something that bothers me here, which is say is say we have an expression--
one single expression that's really long--and we start parsing it this way.
We say let's go left to right. We'll do the first alternative first.
Parse the term, and it parses this big, big long term
and then tries to parse a plus or minus, and it says, oops, I hit the end.
There's no more plus or minus. This alternative fails.
Now I try the second alternative, and the second alternative says
start with a term and we go back and we parse this whole big term all over again.
We've doubled the amount of work, and it can be worse that that,
because inside of each of these terms there's more little pieces,
and we can be doubling each of those pieces work.
That seems really inefficient.
What we'd like to be able to do is fix up our parser so that once we've done this work
we don't have to do it a second time in case this version fails.
Don't worry about doing the work of saying what if like 5 out of 6 of these got parsed,
just worry about the individual atoms, and saying if I did the work of computing
the tree for an individual atom. I don't want to have to repeat that twice.
The quiz question is can you go into here and modify this parse function
so that it has that property that it doesn't repeat the work twice.
Once it's done it once, it's asked to do it a second time, it doesn't repeat the computation.
It just does the computation once.
That may seem like a daunting task, but there is a solution that's really simple
that you have the tools for to be able to solve.